so I may have lost a vote today but as I
walk out of this chamber I feel
fortunate to have served the American
people here is Kevin McCarthy in his
first press conference after being
removed and like here's just a guy
taking it Like A Champion being a pro
doing the right thing isn't always easy
but it is necessary
I don't regret standing up for choosing
government
over grievance
it is my responsibility it is my job
I do not regret negotiating
our government is designed to find
compromise
I don't regret my efforts to build
coalitions and find Solutions
I was raised to solve problems not
create them
so I may have lost a vote today but as I
walk out of this chamber I feel
fortunate to have served the American
people
I leave the speakership with a sense of
Pride accomplishment and yes optimism
you know isn't it interesting because so
far out of everyone we've talked about
today we haven't shown you anyone that's
really like shredded their integrity and
all of this right like Gates is
absolutely doing what he thinks but is
best I completely agree with that and
again whether you agree with it or
whether I agree there's irrelevant like
he's doing what he thinks is best his
Integrity is intact he's telling you
what he thinks and he's doing it
McCarthy right there he could have
thrown everybody under the bus and done
all sorts of stuff but he's walking from
this thing with his Integrity in fact
the Democrats who I just showed you I
don't think they have much Integrity but
they're doing exactly what they always
do which is be in lockstep with each
other and do everything to destroy the
Republicans everyone's kind of doing
their part so far McCarthy went on to
say he will not run for speaker again
because technically he could run for
speaker again he could try to whip up
the votes and do the whole thing all
over again but he ain't gonna do it
my goals have not changed
my ability to fight is just in a
different form
you need 218.
unfortunately four percent of our
conference can join all the Democrats
and dictate who could be the Republican
speaker in this house
I don't think that rule is good
for the institution
but apparently I'm the only one
I believe I can continue to fight maybe
in a different manner
I will not run for speaker again
I'll have the conference pick somebody
else
so again four percent eight Republicans
worked with the Democrats got rid of
this guy one more time doesn't matter if
you think he was great or think he was
awful you have to think about the
mechanism and ultimately is that good
for America and you might say yes you
might say it's it's worth
Gates's move here to get a simpler
system is worth working with the devil
like cutting a deal with the devil
because that that I think in essence is
what this is you might say that but one
more on Kevin McCarthy here he is just
talking about his uh his future in or
out of Congress
I look forward to your positive
questions
oh I'll look at that